-I'm hanging out with
Amanda Seyfried,
and we are about to
play "The Whisper Challenge."
Here we go.
[ Indistinct whispering ]
-"Whisper Challenge."
-You want me to go first?
-Alright, so, here's how
the game works, alright?
Other person puts on
these headphones
with loud music playing.
Then the other person
picks up a card -- okay? --
and reads the random phrase
on the card.
And the person
wearing the headphones
has to try and guess
what they just said.
Alright, Amanda, you will put
the headphones on first.
I will start the music.
Let me know when
you can't hear anything.
[ Humming ] Okay.
Right? Okay, it's good?
Alright, it's happening.
No, you need it more louder.
You need it louder?
Wow. Too loud.
No, it's good.
Alright, good.
Okay. Alright.
Here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
Okay.
April showers bring May flowers.
-April showers
bring May flowers.
-What?!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yes!
-Oh, that's it?
-Yes!
-Oh, yeah.
-Wow!
-When you said, "April showers,"
I was like,
"You're saying 'April show--'
Oh, bring -- Yeah, okay."
-Wow. How did you get that?
You're the first person to get
it the first time out.
-Oh, cool. Yep.
-That was amazing.
Awesome. I didn't know, I swear.
-Alright, here we go.
This is good.
We're good partners.
Alright, hold on a second.
-Alright.
It's really loud. Okay. Ready?
It's good.
I don't know what it is.
-Yeah.
-[ Gasps, moans ]
Cadbury Creme Egg.
-Did you start?
-Cadbury Creme Egg.
-Are you starting?
-Yeah.
-And...action!
-Cadbury Creme Egg.
-Caramel wrappers.
-Caramel me, baby.
-Cadbury Creme Egg.
-Cameron baby.
-Cad-bury Creme Egg.
-Calbert and Hobbes.
-Cadbury Creme Egg.
-Calbert...
-Cadbury --
-Calbert me one...
-Cadbury...
-Calbury...
-Cad-bury.
-Cow-bert.
Cowbert...
-Creme.
-You and me.
-Yume. Cowbert Hume.
-Creme.
-The great author
Calbert Hume, everybody.
-Creme!
-Egg!
-Cadbury Creme Egg!
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow.
Did I scream at you? Sorry.
-I screamed at you.
-Sorry if I screamed --
Oh, you screamed at me?
I couldn't hear you.
Very good. Alright, good.
Sorry about that.
Alright, good. We got two.
This is good.
We're already on a record.
This is big.
Alright, ready?
[ Clears throat ]
[ Chuckles ]
W-2.
-Jumping to.
-W-2.
-Double true.
-Jump -- jumping true.
-W-2.
-Double...
-W.
-2.
-W true.
-Aah!
W-2.
-"Dumbo 2."
-We were so close.
W.
-W.
-2.
-Yes!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Taxes. W-2 form.
-I'm so stupid.
-You're like, "I haven't done
my W-2 in years."
-W-2?
-"I pay somewhere for that."
Alright, here we go.
-There's no -- There --
-Alright, here we go. Ready?
-Yeah.
-Alright, come on. This is it.
For the win.
We already got 50/50.
This is good.
-I didn't --
-We got this.
-Alright, I didn't get that one.
-We got this, bud.
-Okay. Timothée Chalamet.
-Timothée Chalamet?
-Ah! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come on.
-You got it the first,
and I got it first.
-I know.
I got it the first time.
[ Both laugh ]
We're such winners.
-Timothée Chalamet!
Amanda Seyfried, everybody!
The series finale of
"The Dropout"
airs this Thursday on Hulu.
I don't know how I got that.